[Musik]
schöner
freyer
weiter
fortschrittlicher
entspannter
nachhaltiger
sechs menschen auf ihrem ganz eigenen
weg ihr leben zu verbessern
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich bin fast 28 jahre alt und informatik
trainerin für sehbehinderte im
beruflichen umfeld
ich mache die nächsten vier wochen ein
experiment zum thema selbst vermessungen
dazu nutze ich apps und gadgets vor
allem in den bereichen fitness ernährung
und erholung und möchte so sehen ob und
wie ich mein leben damit optimieren kann
ich habe mich vor einigen monaten
verletzt und kommen jetzt gerade aus der
verletzungsphase raus darf jetzt also
wieder im sport starten
ich möchte in dreieinhalb wochen in
pakistan in sursee mitlaufen sind um die
sechseinhalb kilometer mit minimum 20
hindernissen
da muss sich was tun und wenn ich mich
nicht optimiert dann schaffe ich das
nicht ich will meine excel liste aus um
meine ziele zu definieren und die dann
zu überprüfen und zwar würde ich gern
versuchen minimum sieben stunden zu
schlafen das sich beim sport fitter wert
und ich möchte sechs kilo abnehmen messe
tue ich drei bereiche fitness ernährung
und erholung
das sind ja schon viele daten die ich
jetzt persönlich sammeln will
und ja da bin ich jetzt wie kann ich das
am besten da stelle ich hätte am schluss
auch gerne diagramm weil es mir einfach
farblich zeigt wo stehe ich was muss ich
noch machen
und überhaupt auch zu wissen okay was
schaffe ich überhaupt es ist ganz klar
eine selbstreflexion und eine motivation
für mich und ich habe es gern
aufgeschrieben was ich mache was ich tun
muss ich habe gerne hilfe hilfe von den
apps
[Musik]
ich würde gern gewicht verlieren und
meine ausdauer steigern und daher an
trainingstagen 1700 kalorien und wenn
ich jetzt mal nichts mache oder weniger
dann auch weniger kalorien
ich koche ethnischer schucker ich stelle
meine leerung dahingehend dass ich
weniger freund mit rate ist das ist
eigentlich das was jeder kennt darüber
was ich besonders machen möchte ist dass
ich auf getreide und milchprodukte und
komplett auf zucker verzichten will die
technik und vermessung hilft mir
eigentlich dabei so ein bisschen auch zu
sehen dass ich überhaupt in den
lebensmitteln drin ich habe jetzt hat
meine ernährung shrek app geöffnet um
meine zutaten einzugeben und zu scannen
und sie hat mich jetzt auch schon
erinnert dass ich mein abendessen
eingeben soll also passt grad
ich kann das hier jetzt kennen mal
schauen ob sie es gibt sollte ich hier
unter die handykamera und dann wird mir
das angezeigt und kann ich dann
entscheiden ist es richtig und ich kann
doch die portionen aussuchen und es war
jetzt ein teil des bodens und jetzt zb
eine paprika die ist hinterlegt also in
einer normalen größe ich könnte jetzt
auch abbiegen das wäre noch besser und
die würde ich dann einzeln eingeben und
so gibt es dann eben das gericht
insgesamt
und so weiß ganz genau wie viel kalorien
drin sind ohne damit ich mich darauf
verlassen muss was jetzt drauf steht
haye siri timer zehn minuten
ok zehn minuten der kater
meine ernährung umzustellen fällt mir in
gewisser weise schwer
ich würde lügen wenn ich sagen das alles
wie sie und ich glaube die ersten paar
tage ist gar nicht so schlimm weil er
ist die motivation noch sehr groß dass
wirklich durchzuziehen und zu machen
schlimm wird's dann erst wenn man
unterwegs ist und mehr
ich sollte ich eigentlich essen und
alles was ich bekomme zum beispiel beim
bäcker darf ich nicht essen weil kein
getreide und dann fällt einem schon
schwer
ich komme aus einer verletzung genauer
habe ich mir vor vier wochen ein
außenband gerissen im fuß und davor
hatte ich schwere prellung und schwere
halswirbel prellung durch ein reitunfall
und jetzt ist heute das erste mal wo ich
wieder laufen gehen und bin jetzt
gespannt wie es läuft
ich checke meine zielsetzung im fitness
und mit einem gerät war es die ganzen
parameter misst das wäre es in dem fall
meine uhr gemessen wird mein herzschlag
gemessen wird welche strecke laufe ich
mit gps und meine pace das bedeutet wie
schnell bin ich überhaupt und daran
würde ich mich gern so ein bisschen
messen meine größte motivation ist
natürlich möglichst schnell ergebnisse
zu sehen und fit zu werden war kann
immer sagen jetzt bin ich besser
geworden ich fühle mich besser aber
schlussendlich zählt auch nur das was
gemessen wurde
zwei kilometer dauert zwölf minuten 51
einem preis von 6 22
also wie viel minuten brauche ich für
einen kilometer und carolin habe mich
verbrannt
20 38 und meine herzlich wenn es mal im
durchschnitt war 177 noch ein bisschen
hoch max politisch bei mir so bei 185
sei es dann kriege ich keine luft mehr
und wir können nur ein bisschen stabiler
unten seien erst mal noch ein gut ja ich
hab jetzt noch ein bisschen was an wir
haben einfach zu schauen was noch geht
wo ist mein limit meine daten
die wurde ja bereits in der app schon
gesammelt dhs habe ich vorhin schon nach
kontrolliert das steht alles jetzt drin
ich würde die zusätzlich noch in meine
motivation chart einfügen und bin selbst
überrascht dass ich der erste tag war
für mich wirklich sehr überraschend ich
habe immer das gefühl gehabt ich kenne
mich in der sache schon ein bisschen aus
was zu menschen die es betrifft vor
allem wenig überrascht über meine dass
es so gut lief dass ich danach noch
puste hat und es gibt mir hoffnung dass
das ganze auch wirklich in der zeit
klappt wie ich mir das vorgenommen haben
treffe ich mich um christoph um zu
rennen und kraftübungen zu machen
zu zweit macht einfach mehr spaß in
bezug auf sport läuft sehr sehr gut ich
habe angefangen damit meine zwei
kilometer und das auch wirklich gerade
so geschafft und jetzt mit meinem lauf
plan bin ich gestern für ihre halb
kilometer schon gelaufen eine sehr gute
pace und jetzt fehlt einfach noch ein
bisserl die kraft die selbstmessung
hilft neben dem fall sehr gut um mich zu
motivieren ich habe mein plan war eine
app sagt man war nicht zu laufen habe
und vor allem aber auch was ich zu
laufen haben und würde ich das jetzt
nicht so mit messe und nicht nach dem
plan mache dann wäre so wie keine
steigerung und entwicklung zu sehen und
da hilft mir das wahnsinnig
ja ja
[Gelächter]
besser der trend ist kann ich gehabt
zeigen und zwar müssen aus foto machen
für unser doch ist mir das nicht vor
das foto nach dem rennen extra dafür da
dass man sieht was man geleistet hat
ich finde dass die beste motivation also
damals selbst machen genau notiz kann
man noch hinzufügen
sollen wir sagen war super man liest
dass ich zehn minuten 40 sekunden
durchschnittliche pace sechs minuten 21
sekunden genau und hier auf dieser karte
kann strebe noch erkenne an welche
stelle ich jetzt zum beispiel weil es
mein puls gemessen hat im hübschen
pulsbereich war also wirklich ko war
eigentlich immer wieso eigentlich hoch
gegangen ist sieht man was und wo es
runter gegangen ist wieder grün geworden
und so czech ich jetzt jedes rennen
man kann hier auch noch der fortschritt
anzeige und dann sehe ich zum beispiel
hier wie viele kilometer bin ich laufe
und welche pace habe ich im schnitt und
wie viel kilometer insgesamt gelaufen
bin und mein jahresziel 150 kilometer
und 18 davon will schon gelaufen
der fakt dass mir die app sagt wo es zu
tun habe finde ich genial
es schlägt mir einfach was vor ich halte
mich daran und schlussendlich kann ich
mich darauf verlassen und macht es für
mich viel viel einfacher weil ich
einfach dem folge was mir die app sagt
ich bin gerade aufgestanden und wurde
von meiner sleep cycle app geweckt wie
jetzt auch die letzten paar wochen wenn
ich sie abends stellen muss ich nur
sagen band spätestens auf machen möchte
und dann rechnet so eineinhalb stunden
zyklus wo es eben schaut wann ich am
wachsen schon bin und fängt dann an mich
zu wecken also um die nun ganz normaler
wecker die app jack zusätzlich nochmal
ein schlaf das heißt sie hört mir nachts
zu und kann dann durch diese
geräuschkulisse entscheiden die jetzt
mal eine schlafphase im moment ist dann
zeige ich am besten mal was die app
alles kann ich nehme den schlaf von
heute nacht dadurch die möglichkeit
relativ lange zu schlafen das hat sich
auch auf die schlafqualität ausgewirkt
und ja die herzfrequenz die wird eben
morgens auch gemessen und zwar geht dann
hinten bei der kameras licht an kamera
licht und die kamera können da meinen
herzschlag
nachmessen ich weiß nicht ob die app den
schlaf wirklich verbessern kann was mein
größter gewinn von der app ist dass ich
besser auf wache mich so dann auch
fitter fühlen und ich bin viel
aufmerksamer geworden in bezug auf
meinem schlaf
für mich ist man fährt der einzige ort
an dem ich tatsächlich digital frei bin
und deswegen zählt für mich vor allem
zur erholung weil ich ja auch mal
abschalten kann
also ich bin vor zwei monaten vom pferd
gefallen aber auch im krankenhaus aber
es ist für mich eher noch die motivation
noch mal zu überdenken was könnte ich
dann noch besser machen und wir können
nicht so situationen vermeiden
wir gehen hoch auf dem platz also er ist
noch nicht eingerichtet mir schafe im
moment gerade vom bruder aus und
gewinnen an der sattel
aber es reicht noch nicht um freiheit
prima
[Musik]
ja in meinem motivation charts steht was
ich mir vorgenommen habe
und ja gleich sich jetzt immer mehr ab
mit dem was ich erreicht habe meine
großen ziele pro kategorie war ja dass
sich beim sport fitter wert habe ich
tatsächlich geschafft dann zum thema
ernährung habe ich ja gesagt ich möchte
sechs kilo abnehmen
das ist in dreieinhalb wochen schon so
ein bisschen ein krasses ziel und heute
morgen habe ich mich gewogen und ich
habe es tatsächlich geschafft mein ziel
in der erholung mit den sieben stunden
schlaf im schnitt habe ich auch mit
heute oder gestern schon geschafft das
experiment selbst vermessen hat vor
allem dazu geführt dass sich immer
irgendwie leitfaden hatte was ich machen
soll machen muss und machen kann
kritik an der selbstmessung kann ich
eigentlich nur in dem punkt geben dass
man halt sehr sehr sehr viel von sich
preisgibt kann nicht so ganz
kontrollieren wo die daten landen und
vor allem bringt natürlich viel zeit vom
handy sind jetzt meine freunde gewöhnt
aber ich kann mir vorstellen dass jemand
der das auch gerne probieren würde dass
das auch schwierig sein kann weil viel
druck von außen kommt das fängt an mit
ja was trägst studer was machst du da
die ganze zeit du schreibst das auf und
wiegt mit zu einer komischen waage was
ist wenn die daten irgendwie raus kommen
also ich glaube es ist eher das problem
dass diese unsicherheit von außen einen
dann selber unsicher macht es waren
meine groß das was ich erreichen wollte
und heute werde ich am run seinen das
wird erst ab gehabt wenn ich es dann
geschafft
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es gibt noch viel zu tun
ich bin froh dass gemacht haben sind
dreieinhalb wochen
[Musik]
ein bisschen die worte ich glaube dass
heute hat mir gezeigt dass sich das
lohnt das nur dadurch ziele realistisch
erreichen kann
ich habe es einmal alltag eingebaut und
warum sollte ich das nicht machen ich
würd gern ebenso ein bisschen zeigen
dass sich lohnt das anzufangen
und wenn es auch nur massen monat ist um
zu sagen okay ich hab das mal gemacht es
war es sei anstrengend
[Musik]
der launch einen tag also einen
kreislauf könne man den ausgang
konsumieren ohne an die ich merke für
mich dass ich mir dazu führen dass ich
meinen teil sie vor dem sinnlosen konsum
sondern eine bewegung nach ferien
trotzdem ist es schön ins quartier eine
herzensangelegenheit
ich bin goller ich bin 27
mit der stadt zürich oder lange straße
machen wir hatten ursprünglich niedrig
und schlagmann based on waste heißt für
mich dass ich endlich stufen alles
verzichten was unnötig ist spricht ich
auf mich und plastik ich brauche
fröhlich zum im griff
am anfang wusste sache der zahnpasta
oder der ansicht dass ich so einen
konventionellen bausteinen kokosnussöl
und aktivkohle und kokosnussöl ich und
die mikro bakteriellen und anti funkel
und der kanton für alles und aktivkohle
dazu ganz viel aber sie flügge
[Musik]
für die zuschauer ist ein wunderbar
schminke das machen wird gestrichen so
mysteriös kokosöl schmeckt ja aber meine
gewissen punkt jetzt so heiß ich sowieso
aber es gott ganz nahe dran oder drinnen
ist das verhindere dass sich bakterien
bilden beginnen und noch eine gesonderte
und das funktioniert wenn jetzt mal aus
dem überhaupt es bekämpft eigentlich
nicht im dom stinke sondern das am
anfang also dass auch die bakterien dann
stinkt es gibt natürlich auch immer
sachen oder für ist von der ezb vor dass
angefangen und ich schätze dass gott
besonders jahr eine halb bist du all die
sache muss gefasst
also bevor du mit all den sachen fertig
wisch und sich mühsam am anfang mit
vorwärts aber bei der bergtour über das
okay ich habe alles auf und bringt und
das sind viele
zu mittag also dann kein abfall
deponiert oder süchtig was wir kochen
maschinen durch die mitgliedschaft
automatisch und spüli und zucchini tui
das glas sind sehr irritiert
aber weshalb ich haben kann auch von mir
aber nur noch als glaubwürdig kürzung
ich möchte das nicht es ist ein moment
abfall und vieles wohl aber jetzt ein
trainer ist recycling abfall also das
ist ein spiel von links ab und zu gönnt
man sich linse
das sind 47 mal vergessen qualität des
café oder alte ist o'leary und th und
zur direkten art erstmals mit glück
wenigstens noch ein ist nur wann dann
das ist so bodylotion vorderhand endlich
fertig ist
da müsste ich mal mit 18 büro sich jetzt
neunjährigen zweck ich hunger habe und
dann halt die qualität von unterricht
geholt
ich habe das auto kaputt und ich wäre
ein gewisses zugeschnitten und das wäre
okay
optionen aber ich mag den stress nicht
nötig also wie schön international
kompost zu schwierig wenn du so der
pfarrer alle geschäftsprozesse von dem
was mir nicht verbrenne geschickt
das ist ein komplott das eine mandat
damit verhält sich das ziel ist
eigentlich das nicht so bleibt vor dem
abschied
und das manchmal gang das alles mit mir
machen vergabe so wie ich zur erde wird
alles andere zu einer wird möchten zu
hause weg und mache und es stecke meine
kraft die haben dann dann verstehe ich
glaube dass muslime will klickt man
ruhig
servette und stelle ist roger liebi aber
es macht also viel zufriedener bin ich
weiß ich bin mit partnership janina hat
entlockt über die nachhaltigkeit und
ethik ich gerne portion begonnen
denken
aber doch irgendwie optimieren das
machst du bist ganz klar dann next stop
das weckt der chef ist woanders schluss
hat wirklich mit was ich mache ich sie
natürlich schon noch mal ganz spezielles
thema und ganz lässig sondern auch das
mini community arm oder vier in sein
volk und wurde richtig fest
man muss schon sehr engagiert sie damit
dass vom 1
august anders sofort alles könnte sich
die umsätze ich glaube dass ein
qualitätsanspruch begonnen möchtet
umstellen oder so schritt für schritt
ist wie einfach dass man sich da nicht
so selten vor
mit welchen erwartungen voll erfüllen
der ausspruch perfekt sondern sich die
beste option zu ende ist ziel und und
das überall machen also es gibt so viele
sachen komfort anderen
[Musik]
die
für den x games möglich
hast du da mit dem stift die
trainingsschuhe verstand schrieben 487
nah dran bist so ein teil vom in der
bakterienzelle laut also den steglitzer
nicht sensibilisiert dass es unmöglich
war und sich sein halt mega fun obermann
und betriebe so
deine schmidt ich glaube unsere zero
race zwar recht von mir sommer aber wo
ein wille ist ist auch ein weg
irgendwie wird sogar fußball
kompromissbereit
ich muss mir gedanken gar nicht machen
wenn ich habe sondern glaube dass ist in
dieser stadt zürich auf dem ganzen weg
zur möglichst wenig verschwand ich bin
ich recht nach paragraph lebens vorbild
ist sie wurde silvester beim 800
programm natron diese ist geschichte
und so macht man flüssig und das ist
recht lässig also ich denke dass man im
herbst mit getöntem glas und denis
thomalla plastik verpackt
ich glaube finanziell technik und zwar
freundlicher konsumiert günstige
lebensmittel kauf und jetzt hat sich das
wild konsumieren meiner wenigkeit und
mini lebensmittel sind definitiv die
[Musik]
ich bin
märz umfasst muss um zero ist das heißt
ich mir geht es darum möglichst wenig
verschwendet stattfindet ich mache jetzt
mal zehn nach der trauer das organisiert
[Musik]
es ist immer wieder schön zum produkt
und vielleicht noch nicht kennt und
spannend sind
das ist ein komplott kommen
[Musik]
wäre ich bin gern
maicosuel und aktive rolle
wir haben jetzt an dem grafik aber schon
einmal in die am meisten nervt das ist
das markenzeichen wurde und jetzt
punkten sagte wenn ich mit dem berg
vorstelle plastik dressler und ich
benutze müsst zum slalom kugel und
schönen ist es windig zwischen
kino
und im stil und größe jährige sich das
ist aber dafür bezug sei das noch alles
liebe oder um
im alltag
fällt ganz viel mit glück
mich interessiert ob da was durch die
stadt habe den druck gespürt
selber mit schusswaffe wurde
sichergestellt haben da muss man einmal
verletzt
lernen
das experiment
ich glaube dass metro metro werde die
zukunft flüssige gesetz finde und das
jetzt wo der brennenden fähre
da interessiert sind und lässiger aktiv
suchen
das zeigt ja eigentlich dass man
hoffentlich erwartet
[Musik]
ja
jahrgang
ich bin ein cyborg weil ich ein
effizienteren mensch sein will nicht ein
besserer mensch aber ich glaube dass ich
mehr aus meinem eigenen leben rausholen
kann dass ich mehr aus fremden leben
rausholen kann indem ich denkanstöße
vorsah also glaube ich dass ich einen
effizienteren mensch bin aber nicht
besser also besser musste man werten und
ich sehe das gar nicht werden
[Musik]
für mich ist fortschritt der wichtigste
bestandteil vom leben ohne fortschritt
gibt es keine entwicklung
wenn wir jetzt nicht anfangen uns selbst
zu entwickeln denn über menschen
schaffen und die nächste stufe dann
stagnieren wir für alle zeiten und dass
das funktioniert nicht und das ist für
mich weder weder für die zukunft
sinnvoll noch für den menschen sinnvoll
ich trage implantat sehen wir die
funktionen haben
ich bin die mischung zwischen mensch und
maschine sind düster ausreicht gerne
düster lebe also die leute nennen mich
grufti und ich glaube das bin ich im
klassischen sinne auch ich stehe auch
totenköpfe spucken gram pentagramme den
ganzen tag den groove die kitsch
[Musik]
angefangen habe ich mit achtzehn wir
sind hier handle gang und ich habe
gesagt jetzt setze ich mir mal so
einteilen wir haben uns für die kühe die
normalerweise die ohren kaum haben uns
einen chip gesetzt habe ich mir in die
handfläche gespritzt und habe gesagt
jetzt lege ich einfach los und gucken
was ich damit machen kann ich habe
leider nicht viel damit machen können
weil das knowledge gefehlt hat die
community hat gefehlt aber ich war
neugierig war ich fand mich selbst war
ziemlich cool und sagt jetzt einfach los
in meiner rechten hand habe ich ein
laufrad konzert können sieht man leute
nicht nur die narbe meiner linken hat da
sieht man den chip ist ein hifi
konzentriert drin
dann habe ich noch ganz alten das aus 17
jahre alt habe ich hier drin
habe ich ein tier als man spritzen
lassen der ist leider schon tot und das
gleiche habe ich dann hier unten nochmal
aber doch das was ich mache kann ich
kann mein telefon mit meinem job
entspann sich die stelle finden ist das
telefon gesperrt
ich kann eine textdatei hinterlegen als
datensatz eine webseite ich toll finde
an so funktion ich kann mein facebook
profil mind uhr zum einen liegt in
hinterlegen wenn ich das gern möchte
mein steam account für die paranoiden
kann ist für ein bitcoin konto
hinterlegen
ich habe mich für chips entschieden
obwohl es natürlich auch möglich ist mit
meinem gesicht mein iphone zu entsperren
oder wenn man fingerabdruck das heißt ja
nicht dass der fingerabdruck oder das
face unlock weniger praktisch sind im
grunde ist der chip und taktische ich
muss einen vorgang mehr machen aber ich
möchte mit den antrieb schaffen
ich möchte damit ich möchte durch konsum
interesse wecken das heißt umso mehr ich
konsumiere in sachen mit chips mit
upgrades mit webos und was es da alles
gibt versuche ich mit den leuten die das
auch vertretenen markt zu schaffen
das heißt wenn wir konsumieren und wird
irgendjemand irgendwann interesse haben
damit geld zu verdienen
male body modification und meine siebte
mal implantaten effektiv keine funktion
das ist rein durch mein aussehen ändern
möchte er
[Musik]
ich habe mal kennengelernt als ich einen
vortrag gehalten habe und er hat sich
als zuschauer gemeldet
wir vertreten uns gegenseitig in der
öffentlichkeit also wir teilen sehr viel
in unserem spektrum unserer wahrnehmung
unserer realitätswahrnehmung und wir
haben den gleichen gedanken
ich holte basel eingeladen über
transfers zu sprechen
über das ibook leben weil ich mich das
selber bezeichnet und bisschen
aufklärung zu treiben den leuten zeigen
was wir tun und ein bisschen mit den
leuten erklären was wir dafür tun die
leute sind mutig hier sind bereit sich
eine andere rolle zu begeben sind bereit
anderen menschen zu akzeptieren und sind
auch bereits neue ideen anzuhören also
ich finde das sehr gut sagt wir haben
gestern sogar gesprochen du hast gesagt
du würdest jetzt auf dein leben dann
physisches leben verzichten und
digitaler form weiter zu leben
du würdest jetzt schon den schritt
machen und würde es nicht bis ins alter
warten absolut hast du keine angst vor
der unendlichkeit
für mich ist nun endlich hat nicht so
ein problem weil wenn mein körper haben
der immer funktioniert er immer fähig
ist da ist verstehe ich den punkt nicht
warum die unendlichkeit ein problem sein
sollte weil ja möchte jetzt nicht
stärken warum sollte ich in 1000 jahren
stärken wollen wenn ein geologischer
körper ja dann nicht endlich zu einem
ende kommt dann ja dann legt doch die
maschine weiter aber durch selbst wisse
dann trotzdem am ende gekommen
ja also für mich aus kopie dann geht das
genauso weiter ausführt und mein leben
weiter hat als die kopie aber die
entwicklung die danach starb wenn du
hast bin weiterhin ich also ich mache
eine digital ist eine digitale kopie vom
verstand vom gehirn an dem punkt das
heißt ich bin eins zu eins dasselbe an
dem punkt wo ich gespalten
das heißt ich verändere mich erst danach
endlich will science fiction blut ich
glaube mein top loading ist nicht es
keine fantasie aus der science fiction
ich glaube ich dass wir zu viel science
fiction geguckt haben
ich glaube dass uns science fiction den
mut gegeben hat wünsche zu äußern dass
ein geist und ein bewusstsein
digitalisiert wird ist tatsächlich
irgendwann möglich dass ein geist an
zwei stellen digital existieren kann als
kopie als clown man das dann immer
aussieht das wird auch passieren
bisher leben wäre das eine andere
geschichte
dass man einen geist in einen anderen
körpers worten kann ist dass bodies
worten oder wird es worten das wird auch
passieren wenn du dir vorstellst du bist
sterbenskrank du hast die möglichkeit
dein bewusstsein in einen anderen körper
zu stecken oder digital weiter zu leben
für alle zeiten
die leute werden das wollen
[Musik]
ich bin die schweiz gekommen weil in
basel eine cocktailbar manager gesucht
hat was mein spezialgebiet ist also ich
arbeite mit cocktails ich bin eigentlich
der klassische barkeeper arbeit
inzwischen aber eher in der
geschäftsführung aus bahnmanager ich
kümmere mich um konzepte ich kümmere
mich schon das angebot und eigentlich
was administrativ drum herum passiert
im beruf merkt man eigentlich nichts von
meinem privatleben es kann passieren
dass jemand meine arme sieht und das was
auffällt dass ich implantate trage
grundsätzlich trenne ich das ganz
bewusst und ich finde beruf hat es uns
zu suchen und das ist mein privates
pressure soll auch nicht ein beruf
reflektiert werden der mensch ist an
einem punkt angelangt tor stagniert wir
haben keine entwicklung mehr
ich glaube nicht dass mensch glücklich
ist wenn er einfach auf dem stand bleibt
wo er ist eine rein geistige entwicklung
reicht mir nicht und es ist auch
tatsächlich für die zukunft nicht
ausreichend es muss eine körperliche und
physische entwicklung geben
das heißt ja nicht dass das eine das
andere ausschließen muss aber das eine
kann durch das andere folgen wenn wir
geistige entwicklung durchmachen durch
bewusstes leben bewusst dass
informationen konsumieren und so weiter
und so fort
entwickeln wir automatisch das bedürfnis
auch physische entwicklung zu haben das
ist ganz normal wenn du dir über deinen
körper so bewusst bist dann möchtest du
makel entfernen
du möchtest schwachstellen entfernen
[Musik]
meine schilddrüse ist nicht gesund und
für mich ist natürlich ein persönliches
interesse dass ich irgendwann die
schilddrüsenfunktion die dieses ding
momentan noch trägt mit einer maschine
ersetzen kann ganz klar ich möchte nicht
darauf verzichten ich möchte das
ersetzen
ich möchte nicht frage hier sein ich
möchte nicht auf körperfunktion
verzichten müssen wenn ich die
möglichkeit habe meine schilddrüse die
nicht richtig funktioniert durch eine
maschine zu ersetzen die piekfeinen
funktioniert solange sie anständig
behandelt dass das absolut größte also
ich würde wahrscheinlich noch maschinen
mehr vertrauen aus meiner eigenen
angriff ist
[Musik]
menschen die mir nahestehen wir sind das
gewohnt ist sein dass die spinne mal
wieder der macht es mal wieder in andere
quatschen kommt mal wieder auf eine
spinnerei und tut sich das an
also man wird viel belächelt aber auf
eine respektvolle dass man im feld
es gibt tatsächlich kritiker die das
sehr verurteilen das gibt es natürlich
auch um das geht bis zu beschimpfungen
hin
das gehört dazu aber ich wurde noch nie
irgendwie angegriffen und sind davon so
deformiert beleidigt oder so dass ich
sagen dass ich muss das verstecken oder
so das auf keinen fall
[Musik]
so alles falsch
ist ein bisschen größer als die haupt
es wird lustig ich lass mir ein xp chip
implantat setzen das tolle an dem chip
ist er kann meine körperwärme an der
stelle wo ist mir implantieren
analysieren und ich kann es aus werth
mit dem gerät und ablesen könnte man
aber ich finde das 40 es kann einfach
sein das ist ein muskel erwischt ein
bisschen ist nicht so schlimm wie es
klingt ich habe ja es tut weh aber es
ist nicht so tragisch aber ich will
nicht genug narben geht's ja schon
einige chips gesetzt
die andere schon einige checks der salbe
mittlerweile und ich bezahle ich beachte
fahrers oder mit der schaufel steril und
eigentlich kein problem darstellen
der chip ist steril in der nadel drin
das sieht man auch nicht wenn man es
implantiert und wird dann durch die
kanüle in die haut rein gedrückt
gehe ich einfach mit 42 cent genau das
was da über stört ja ich glaube da wird
weh tun kann so ein konzert der zieht er
war ja alles gut alles gut
damit die pflaster tiptop
danke auch für tot
[Musik]
ich möchte eigentlich meine komplette
identität auf meinem chip haben das
fängt bei einem schlüssel an dass ich
meine tür öffnen darf also meine
berechtigung meine idee karte mal eine
bewilligung am besten noch und mein geld
das möchte ich alles haben ich möchte
mich von diesem zurückgefragt mike ist
schon dabei der kann seine tür schon
öffnen
er kratzt aber auch mit den fingern
wasser bezahlen darf wir warten
eigentlich nur darauf dass uns das
jemand gestattet musik war für mich
immer absolut wichtig also in jeglicher
hinsicht
mein ziel ist es tatsächlich diese
ganzen knöpfe die ich hier habe überall
verteilt habe das kann ja nichts anderes
als niedriger das heißt hinter jedem
knopf und ihr in jeder bewegung ist ein
kleines signal
das wird an meinem computer gesteckt der
computer macht das was ich hier drücke
ich möchte das hier drauf übertragen das
ist ein kleines eeg gerät damit kann ich
moment in kleinen roboter steuern
das ist ein kleiner hubschrauber sieht
aus wie eine droge mit dem kann ich
ungefähr drei bis vier befehle ausführen
ich möchte aber jeden befehl den ich
hier habe überall möchte ich mir über
eingetragen skate und einem eeg gerät
was über hirnströme funktioniert
komplett steuerlich trigger eigentlich
befehle in dem ich daran denke dass war
die konzentration das sind die das sind
die hirnwellen die von diesem gerät
erfasst werden und umso besser die
natürlich sind umso mehr ausschläge habe
ich hier oben
das heißt sollte ich mich gerade hier
oben drauf konzentrierte geht meine
meditation hoch wenn ich wirklich
überlegen muss was ich sagen will zum
beispiel also das kann ich gerade mal
probieren habt ihr wieder hochgeht ja
das ist jetzt hoch ich fange ich an zu
konzentrieren und sie wird hoch also
wenn ich natürlich eine eg hat mit 32
ablesen punkten
anstatt nun einen dann kann ich
natürlich deutlich mehr effizienz
herausholen
das heißt in der
utopische vorstellung dass ich das
jemals schaffen sollte könnte ich mich
voll auf meinen stuhl sitzt und alle
steuern ohne einen finger krumm zu
machen
[Musik]
ich gehe davon aus dass wir mit der
technik verschmelzen und ich gehe davon
aus dass es unabdingbar ist ich gehe
davon aus dass es in einer gewissen zeit
tatsächlich so normal ist dass man sich
eher wunder dass es nicht früher
passiert ist der chip funktioniert
tadellos die spannung ist weg das
grundwasser ist weg und er macht seinen
dienst einwandfrei ich bekomme konstante
körpertemperatur wärme von der stelle
ohne ich bin mehr als zufrieden er hat
wunderbar funktioniert
ich möchte meinen körper jederzeit
überwachen können also meine motivation
ist die medizin
ich möchte jederzeit auf meinem ipad
oder was auch immer ich dann benutze
alles sehen was in meinem körper vorgeht
und blutzucker bis zum einer
muskelentzündung bis zu meiner
zahnfleisch rückbildung bis zu meinem
haarwuchs alles ich möchte jeden punkt
nachvollziehen können und somit aus
steuern können
möchtest du den punkt die siege ob ich
den tod besiegen möchte wenn ich mutig
bin ja ganz ehrlich wenn ich die
möglichkeit hätte ein echtes leben in
der unsterblichkeit zu verbringen und
man tod selber bestimmen zu können das
wäre wahrscheinlich das größte was ich
was ich erreichen könnte und ich möchte
ist ich könnte tatsächlich mein
potenzial völlig ausschöpfen wolle ich
habe dieses zeitfenster nicht mehr
das ist der kernpunkt wo wir hinwollen
[Musik]
sehen sie gleich im zweiten teil und
sitzt noch tief und glückliche starkes
das ist ja im moment raus allen druck
raus da wo sehen sie jetzt im zweiten
teil
und jetzt noch zwischen 100 glückliche
status das ist ja im moment raus allen
druck raus ja weil es ist nicht so dass
man meinen der luchs der klick
[Musik]
a
apa
[Musik]
ich bin's mit ihrem boot transformation
und vergleichen trip es soweit optimiert
dass irgendwann alles ziemlich freche
spanien 28 schafe als webcam gehört und
pornodarstellerin und wenn sie kurzem
aus konnte durch spanien glaube ich bin
allgemein als personengesellschaft
gemacht
danke also erst geben wenn ich falle
mittelpunkt stand
impressionen
[Musik]
damit nutzt wenig was ich hier mache
laden als rechner immer noch letztlich
immer man zu natürlich die man jetzt
eine spritze und sich überschlug bord
übertrieben
[Musik]
er vermisst hauptsache ich mit meinem
schoß hauptstadt machen
[Musik]
die sexuelle lust immer mehr show die
frauen eingefunden
drei monate lang mit mir fröhlich
verrichten
es gab keinen ball ist nichts richtig
also nicht lange freuen
[Musik]
das ziel von mir ist mich natürlich
seinen körper ca
min ball ist einfach lustig
barbie ist plastik das ist eine nacht
und so hat man aus
also haltefrist dürfen nicht einerseits
will er ein buch ist hohl in der bibel
wird das buch polizei hat das toll
in den steilen hang erholt
am schönsten ist nicht einmal anfängt
alles nochmal vor nach der strafe der
strafe straffrei zu einer collage mit
material tun und schadeten und weiß ich
auch offen ich sehe aber wieder anders
und wieder im ziel hollywood-schönheit
ideal
das ist nicht so das adrenalin
ausschüttet oder wo auch immer der
mehrzahl mit schmerzhaft aber man hat so
freude
das ist schon wichtig dass ich von
meiner letzten außen ab mit stehen lässt
man ein haus auf zeit ein bisschen
dauern
aufgeschnitten da ich machte letzte
große op kings 3 teilige ist immer
extrem mehr haben so mache ich das jetzt
kein sport macht schon mal von gordon in
umlauf
vor allem aber noch
[Musik]
der sarg war schon relativ früh
eigentlich für lolo ferrari elektrische
dienst sid michaela tief wie jung sie
und ich habe immer schon mega auch klima
hat also schon ich habe richtig so und
feiertag und das nehme wie das antike
und war das auch so interessant finde
ich muss das einfach aus und wachsen und
wieso das bonner und wettkämpfen ganz
verwehren verdienen und dass alles okay
und dann eins nach dem andern operieren
und im interesse der sportler davon
ihres nächsten operiere
also das ist ungefähr das ist ziemlich
genau 69 minijob baby ganz schlimm wenn
ihr also er bekommt einen weg finden es
schlecht wenn man jetzt machen
es gibt ja ich begrüße es dass die hits
doch mit ja vier persönliche fouls nun
hat sie natürlich aus bisschen besser
voller schlussendlich muss sie müssen
genauso wie nicht nicht lover lover
dezimieren 30 habe mir zwar tipps für
mich die umsetzen oder nicht ich kann
mir über lagen also habe ich habe gesagt
ich finde es nicht so gut denke ich mir
zu wenig machte sehr schwach ranis ii
und sich wohlfühlen und irgendwann merkt
sich selig zauber und wandert dann
erzähle man sofort dass es hat einfach
so produziert dann ist ja richtig
[Musik]
angriff nach jetzt ganz genau für wen
die schweiz kurzum ich generalüberholen
eine us militär gelebt was sind für sie
die kosten ganz schlimm vor und
meerwasser und es gibt auch einfordern
wird das ist alles so jetzt müssen
der svww das richtige richtig eingesetzt
haben ich mach das weg was ich mir dass
davids
[Musik]
da griffen herzen ganz wenig
ich habe mir alles im cartoon sich das
ist so die projekte beschrieben
okay wer hat das recht auf liebe und
jetzt nochmal tief und adrenalin schmerz
wo sich die gemacht
es ist vergleichbar wäre am anfang stand
wahrscheinlich erst mal warum warum
warum du nicht mit körper das aber warum
und sobald es fertig ist dann ist das so
schnell und so dominant 17
das könnte die nummer was ist nicht
schnell aber lieber ich wirklich etwas
erreichen schmerzhaften stich sonne
ja
[Musik]
das ist
[ __ ] lifestyle entspannt etwas von der
stelle wo die building was ich höre
zufrieden ich glaube [ __ ] lifestyle
apps von kostspieligen abstrich machen
und viel dafür tun aber da muss er das
aber wissen was ist wichtig mir macht
das freude ein anderer macht freude
wolfgang niebergall für 100 200 stück
ich war mir das gerade lieber tore
machen man sich kaputt oder eben großen
krippe vornehmen nur dass ich sagen nur
dass sich sauber glückgriff damit ist
das alles freude macht und nicht für
einen auftritt von fans also so schema
mini fans freuen was mit mir jetzt sei
es aber nur mir einer sagt dass er das
machen was mir im winter das machen
[Musik]
ja
und so gestaltete sich ob die
kosmetische eingriffe
[Musik]
als meister im moment viel stil und mit
gefahren alles was mit puzzles zu haben
[Musik]
etwas kommt zum 1 1
ich habe gott sei dank sehr schön ich
bin halt 35 - eltern und meine ältere
sie will die am ball die 100 prozent
geschafft
und was passt viel dass man müht sich so
umgestaltet dass es schlimm ich hingegen
das trauma oder irgend sowas
das ist jetzt bei mir mit glück auch
nicht was nicht
[Musik]
jetzt sehe ich mich letztlich langsam
nach osten voran ich habe immer kommt es
ganz schlimm kommt rechts kam es nicht
wohl gefühlt und bin jetzt friedrich sie
mit mir und jetzt einfach eine separate
dass keiner zeit erfordere mitteilen
mit der operation im griff und jetzt
jetzt bin ich was ich vorher nie wie ich
mir das vorstelle wenn ich mir das
wünsche ich mir gefällt und nicht
traurig oder so dass ich natürlich das
ziel das ist was genau mit 50
[Musik]
juni
my name is ja nich bis 72 jahre alt wie
natural bodybuilder und online
unternehmen und jeden tag über der
millionen-marke soziale medien
das motto ist jedes stück besser zweite
oder macquarie würde hier golfteam
dennis losito legende trainierte der
schwarzeneggers elf sauber große
inspiration und darin jedem erhöht mit
einer sehr bekannte manager bodybuilder
mit dem spender stoffe besser bekannt
ist
bekannteste gesicht der sportszene 4
millionen follower instagram wie groß
die szene die schon ist die haie zwar
zurück aber wenn man sie genau ob man
einfach das ist noch gar nicht möglich
das ist wenn es alien und die einfach da
haben wir doch mal zu tragen
auch nach neun jahren welches geht immer
noch durchaus immer noch profile beste
zweiten schritt die oft so limitiert und
zeigt also es geht es genetisch limit
sich nach zwei jahren noch zwei jahre
ich glaube es ist eher stehen recht
interessant ist wenn du sag ich dir
abgeschlossen
das ist dass sie werde die nun bessere
denn dann wäre schon besser aber so lang
meinte wenig geld wie sie von abi
gemacht aber wie soll die sonde probiert
und darum muss der autorin mit menü zu
protestieren
120 km und 520 noch nie gemacht
so gelangen
[Musik]
ich muss sagen ich auch in die
kernkunden wie jeder fürs video es gegen
island
das ist das buch auf youtube und wenn
das mal stoppte viatu ist möglich click
game
ich habe das dann fix machen
[Musik]
ja ja genau das gut
außerdem wünsche ich mir dokumentiert
und entsprachen oder das ist so wie
geschichte außerdem gehörte tag müssen
wir selber hat es ist mit büchern über
die ganze sache wie jetzt das abrufen
wenn man die führung hat hier in der
presse es wird um diesen herren blieb
und das ist auch schön aber wenn es mit
der welt teilen muss das doch
kommentiert darum firmen müssen
[Musik]
bodybuilder stehe immer noch nie negativ
verliert das ist sehr oberflächliche
sport aber die finger wenn man tendenz
dazu womit beschäftigen
reflektierende umspielt wurde ganz tagen
trainiert und das reflektierte hat
peugeot rcz reflektiert und die einfach
gemerkt heimischer durch nur so viel
besser da was über die
trennungsmodalitäten sixpack oder dicke
beats selbst behoben
[Musik]
damit sind wir knapp vor hawaii wo also
gäste vor der acht stunden den sturm
ried locker ja ich möchte so wie jeden
tag kraft für mir schon wichtig was ich
das ritual wenn ich schon so unbeständig
um gewerks bienenstock denn wo die
menschen sie die tour auch am morgen
über machen weil ich glaube jetzt die
zonen in hawaii bis 240 euro
aber die kaffee oder stimmung nachdem
ihr nachwuchs nach der ersten stunde
runter und so also ein jahr keine zwei
dutzend infrastruktur der schweiz
nämlich aber trotzdem zwei jahren noch
tapfer und brav meine steuern zahlt und
dass stars nicht momentan mache dann im
berater haben nach einer residenz in
panama kurz nach mittag gemeldet
und da spare ich natürlich jetzt so
studer
also ihr heim es in der regel wenn ihr
nicht mindestens zehn menschen
da kam eine ort lieber ein paar
regalmeter digitale nomaden das heißt
thailand und südafrika für das haupt
jahr ziemlich für jetzt für günstige die
günstige sachen wo man geld spart
thailand und denn hier haben uns also
doppelte vermieter schweizer durchgang
und cassandra büroleiter würdig sagt man
dem jahren die günstige region erlangen
wenn ihr jetzt so zurückblicke bin ich
glaube die letzten drei jahren opfer 25
bisher ist irland xii
und das wirkt und wird vom office of
laser was geht da ab und rennt sie grund
dass ich mir das überhaupt längst erhöht
sich natürlich würde ich aber mini
skills sowie tus bildete das sie
schwangere märz kopieren sie haben jetzt
schon als kind geeignet wo aber über das
normale fitnesstrainer nivose geht es
ihm aber anfang an wissenschaftlich mit
der ganzen materie auseinandersetzen
denn natürlich okay dass das gilt
natürlich auch super praktisch sieht das
heißt wie die szene immer gewachsen und
gleichzeitig kunst medium in die das
ganze transportiert haben die soziale
medien im richtigen moment hat einfach
explodiert und das ist damit operiert
dass sie nicht im gym b&m person
trainiert ist unter den online kurs
machen wo in der ersten zwei jahre über
4000 glück hofft er jetzt in der nacht
in den letzten zwei jahren trifft sich
die zu hause das jahr mit wieder über
acht du sie glüht miniprogramm gemacht
und die verkäufe im durchschnitt
zwischen 150 und 250 franken
[Musik]
monik bio ranch geschafft hat wird mir
für verrückt erklärt was durch undichte
stelle hier
der lohn ist an der schlachte sie nur
mal für youtube-videos wie wort steht
und glaubt für die jenaer geht es damals
noch nicht begriffen und hört sich dass
die militärische durch glück kann
[Musik]
ja aber momentan marcel möbius und
marcel schenk oder weniger gras oder
beim regen die story video drei der fünf
schnitte zu youtube hat das heißt er hat
nur wenige stühle oder das heißt wenn du
wirklich wort troika muss studie zieht
definitiv auswärts betrachter wertvoller
scout auf jeden fall größer punkt und so
haut wirkt man auch ganz gezielt das
heißt dass ich leute jetzt jeden bh das
online es erstens haben sie friedrich
stück ist die sache beim namen für mehr
und so gar nicht nach einer creme mit
dem orchester und sehr schmutzwasser so
kann hier oben in die zwölf stunden
jimmy lidberg wirtschaftskraft geschäfts
meetings machen oder was ihr sehr
wichtig finger und kritik an ihrem
boyfriend bliebe also workaholic und das
wollte ich gar nicht und ich finde dass
das eine form der wichtigste faktor ist
optimiert betrifft wie der moment wo du
aus dem hamsterrad ausbricht oder der
größten jüdischen staat karriereleiter
aber wenn man erst mal ausstieg unseres
versiegte nalut x7 habe dass das
eigentliche preistreiber du hast noch so
viel verdienen aussah oder das weiß
präsident du willst es in moskau
du wirst nie wirklich der spaß machen
und wenn menschen sie das autocross demo
sowie die frage ob das überhaupt noch
[Musik]
hallo
das heißt dass keine ganzkörper wunsch
nach einer klage über die körper wie zum
beispiel körperfett knoche durch die
brille skoliose mir interessant dem
logan bailly linke sich danach mit mir
dachte wenn ich trainiere und das
jetzige ergebnis ist interessant
muskelmasse natürlich wurde das heißt
entschieden der bislang nicht so
das papier habe bewiesen dass es so gut
[Musik]
mit dem david goldman sicher facharzt
über das thema landes verlängern
interessant ist erst 36 man dieses
feidmans auf net gaming mouse over to
strike at you to be ready for take off
in the informers of gaming mit 45 jahren
ist einziger um interessiert hat wie
nino muskulös
jetzt geht es mir darum wie kann ich
noch sünder werden animiert tag um das
ganze team ob das jetzt reise ich habe
ja schon bewusst in schädigt hoffe dass
das nur schwer die schweiz in jeder
wohnung aussieht woche
dass ich das auto abgeschafft wenn oder
und darum probiert jetzt immer als
optimal musiker aber sie natürlich
definitiven im ausland gedacht die
männer ist wichtig also weniger
irgendwoher flüge und mehr woche planen
das private muss es ist chinas problem
was ich hab mich
[Musik]
ich konsumiere marihuana ab und zu am
für habe
[Musik]
es muss wirklich jeder jeden wirkstoff
koffein marihuana auf os geglüht die
betrage das beste das gebiet vertrages
nicht so gut durch das kann aber sowohl
übt eigentlich gar nicht die option und
auch problemfamilie knüpfen aber für
mehr
das ist sehr gut für sie ist auch gar
nicht bewusst dass alkohol programm sehr
viel kalorien das ist fast so viel wie
fett und selbstoptimierung smi nicht
allgemein verfahrens blieben sondern aus
ähnlich ausprobieren und sie zwingen ist
es ein bisschen mitbringt sowie bieten
wir ein video game ohne joystick drückt
einfach nur von luxus passiert und wenn
du die nicht nur falsch bewusst setzte
im richtigen moment die richtigen moment
extrem wie stufe bringen
perfektion ist es was auch jederzeit
wieder weg der weg zum bau oder in
punkto dokumente ist es ist perfekt wie
viele tiere das ist nicht perfekt das
heißt perfektion hänge nach erzählerisch
fehler und geradezu führen dass wir
irgendwann eine sehr unglückliche rolle
wiederfinden
[Musik]
mixa hat challandes mini glücklich und
ich locker und das ist ne glück oder
weniger schlecht geht glücklicher status
ist ja im moment und bürger aber
glücklich damit sind die närrischen
thing ist aber auch als series kurz
zweifach weiterhin glücklich
[Musik]
und dann kannst du auch mal die beine
ist nach oben nehmen zum himmel ein
bisschen aus strecken die arme zu nehmen
und auch richtig so fußgelenk heraus
schütteln handgelenk heraus schütteln
bewegen aus der hüfte heraus die beine
bewegen die arme ellenbogen schultern um
auch richtig alles raus schütteln alle
anspannung raus allen druck raus ja wohl
kräftig und alles raus ja wunderbar sehr
gut
ba management tätig im großen
internationalen konzern
ich habe gemerkt über die jahre hinweg
der druck wird einfach zu groß ich
arbeite sehr viel und ich entferne mich
immer mehr so von meiner essenz viel
geld verdienen immer höhere rendite mehr
mehr profit die klassischen themen in
der wirtschaft und die befriedigung
wurde immer weniger
am ende ist es kumuliert den
körperlichen ich bin krank geworden hab
dann die klassischen stresssymptome
bekommen verspannungen druck
schlafstörungen aggressivität und dann
auch eine schwere gehirnblutung bekommen
und das war für mich ein zeichen dass es
so nicht mehr weitergeht
seine schultern der 49 stückchen näher
zum boden sinken werden
[Musik]
die zentrale ist es an sich zu arbeiten
sich weiter zu entwickeln oder man
könnte auch sagen so ich selber zu
optimieren ich glaube ich schon sehr
essentiell
es ist die frage mal in welcher phase
meines lebens stehe ich wo stehe ich
gerade habe ich die ressourcen dazu habe
ich die kraft dazu habe ich die zeit
dazu und oft was ich beobachte ist der
druck auch groß genug um etwas zu ändern
und es braucht schon auch immer wieder
an einfluss von außen muss etwas
passieren damit ich für mich reflektiere
geht so weiter möchte ich so weiterleben
oder kann ich etwas an mir ändern
mein mann trat es nicht mal gehört hab
von meiner mutter ich liebe meine mutter
ihr wisst ja auch was sollen denn die
nachbarn denken du mit deinen
verrissenen rosen und die komische musik
die du da hörst und ein komisches auto
wurden probiert dosen drin also ich war
als pubertierender ist halt so ist
damals auf dem dorf nahe
was sollen denn die nachbarn dinge aber
wenn ich das natürlich so absorbieren so
angepasst lebe ich ja nicht mein leben
sondern das leben von meinem nachbarn ja
ich mache mir nicht lustig über diese
menschen er versteht weil wenn diese
prägung so stark sind ist schwierig da
rauszukommen
also ich erkenne diese prägung diesen
glaubenssatz und jetzt üblich denn
anzunehmen ich will halt beliebt sein
ich kann nicht nein sagen oder ja ich
bin halt pedantisch ich bin perfekt und
ich muss das jetzt alles zum 13 mal
nachrechnen
das ist jetzt so und dann habe ich eben
das umzuwandeln
möchtest du nach vorne kommen genau
möchtest du dich mal so hinstellen wie
du dich wohl fühlst so ist der abstand
zur ordnung ganz sie auch mal schließen
ganz bewusst jetzt die füße wahrnehmen
ist in kontakt haben mit dem boden
die aufrichtung wahrnehmen
schultern aussortieren für den
hinterkopf noch ein stückchen mehr nach
hinten und dem war wie du jetzt da
stehst geehrten kraftvoll ganz stabil
fest
und während du so atmest bist du ganz
bei dir
es liest jetzt sitze vorn dass diese
sätze einfach mal auf die schwierigen
schauen was passiert
ich akzeptiere was ich nicht ändern kann
ich muss nicht alles kontrollieren
störungen sind teil des jobs ich bleibe
gelassen auch wenn ich nicht weiß was
kommt gibt es da einsatz bei dem du eine
resonanz spürst einsatz der dich
anspricht
möchtest du uns sagen haben sie alles
kontrollieren
sehr schön sagt den satz noch mal in
deiner mundart so wie es für dich
stimmig ist
tief einatmen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
man sagt den satz noch mal sagt
einsatzleiter im moment aus kontrolliert
noch lauter er muss nicht aus
kontrollieren und kräftig laut ich muss
nicht auskommt sollte jeder seine linke
hand auf dein herz und die rechte hand
auf die linke hand sagt den satz noch
mal und noch mal
vielen herzlichen dank für die schöne
übung das hast du wahrgenommen über
verlauf der übung wie lautet einsatz und
kontrollieren den wiederholst du jetzt
jeden tag kannst du diese post it zettel
klebst du auf den kühlschrank drauf was
steht auf dem posten zettel drauf da
gehst ins badezimmer schränkchen macht
sein spiegelschrank aufgeklebte post-it
mit was für umsatz und dann machst du
deine wurzeln eine schranktür auf vom
kleiderschrank
sind wir ganz gut
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
und je mehr ich in die ruhe komme je
mehr ich eben diese gedanken zur ruhe
bringen den geist zur ruhe bringen desto
mehr komme ich immer mehr bei mir an und
gerade in unserer gesellschaft die eben
sehr stark geprägt ist durch materielle
dinge durch materiellen wohlstand durch
glücksversprechen im außen ist es nicht
einfach und oft erkenne ich auch wenn
ich mit meinen klienten auch intensiver
zusammenarbeit ich liebe orte des
rückzugs einfacher im kloster dort
blühen sie auf
[Musik]
also ich hatte ein schlüsselerlebnis das
mich sehr stark geprägt hat sich wurde
schwer krank und lag im krankenhaus und
das war nicht glaube ich diese nacht
überleben
und ich hatte eine ganz tiefe ruhe ganz
großen frieden und das war das erste mal
wo ich gespürt habe ich kann es nicht in
worte fassen damals nicht heute nicht wo
ich gespürt habe es wird alles gut oder
ist es schon alles gut und es war für
mich schon eine wichtige erfahrung dass
ich vertrauen darf und es war für mich
auch eine wichtige erfahrung dass da
etwas ist was ich lange lange gesucht
habe auch wenn es nicht in worte fassen
kann und das möchte ich näher
kennenlernen erkunden
[Musik]
kommt meine arbeit bei den leuten an
ich glaube schon es ist ich vergleiche
wie so ein kleiner samen der gepflanzt
wird oder gesät wird und aus diesen
samen kommt ein kleines pflänzchen und
das muss gegossen werden gehegt werden
gepflegt werden und irgendwann kommt da
vielleicht ein bisschen raus und
irgendwann eine kleine blüte und das ist
so sehe ich auch meine arbeit ich kann
am ende kann ich keinen menschen helfen
und retten und das ist auch nicht mein
anspruch dass wir vermessen was sich
menschen mitgeben kann ist eben eine
andere sichtweise ich kann eben eine
erfahrung schildern ich kann ihnen
übungen mitgeben techniken ich kann
ihnen sichtweisen zeigen aus den
asiatischen business lehren
ich kann sie zum nachdenken anstoßen ist
der platz hier ok möchte dich
woandershin legen ja wo man seinen kopf
hingegen hier oder genau dann bringe ich
dir noch ein kopfkissen oder eine decke
hast du uns sensiblen rücken
also möchte was unter die knie gehen ist
das gut so möchtest du dich zu decken
okay gut und dann mal ganz bewusst jetzt
hier ankommen in dem körper den körper
wahrnehmen noch wahrnehmen wie dein
körper jetzt schwer wird sein kiefer ist
locker deine zähne berühren sich nicht
was lastet auf der auf dem unteren
rücken
[Musik]
zugs besonderen wie hast du da
wo stehst du jetzt in diesem elternhaus
in deinem zimmer den sturz zieht es soll
es allein können wir auf darunter sieht
das ist meine sache gut
was braucht die partie jetzt in dem
moment wo sind da steht in diesem zimmer
weiß es einfach viel zu viel zu viel
schulaufgaben schaffen dann für den
vater noch da sein müssen oder wollen
was braucht die pet gleich nicht gab und
klasse möchtest du jetzt als starke
erwachsene frau mit der ganzen kraft die
du hast jetzt zu der partie gehen und
seefest den arm nehmen
und sagen dass du für sie da bist ja
gott was derzeit
wie reagiert sie
sie darf
vielleicht und dabei
dann lasse ich jetzt mal geschlossen hat
immer ganz bewusst tief durch die nase
ein bisher den bauch kraftvoll
halt eine ende kräftig kraft noch mit
lange die ohren den kopf hinterkopf
kräftig alles kräftig rein und die
schulden dann aber richtig aus streit
mit dem körper alles weg alles weg noch
mehr weg alle gegen alle trauer aller
schmerz weg weg
wasser das derzeit dem
wo stehe ich auf meine reise eine sehr
gute frage ich
ich sehe mich am anfang
ich glaube es ist nie abgeschlossen
es ist ein ständiges lernen das ist
ständiges erfahren und auch immer wieder
sicherlich auch mit rückschlägen
verbunden auch mal mit phasenweise im
stillstand aber kontinuierlich
entwickelt sich etwas
also könnte es salopp sagen haben sagt
zusammenbruch ja war schon auch mein
glück dass es eben da eine neue tür
geöffnet hat sozusagen ihr wollt das ist
jetzt etwas mit der erfahrung die ich
gesammelt habe im positiven wie im
negativen kann ich jetzt einen schritt
weiter gehen und kann jetzt etwas tun
was eben andere menschen auch hilft was
sie unterstützt was ihnen vielleicht
orientierung bietet
[Musik]